welcome back to grammar filtered host by
me josh smith and today
we are joined by the new queen of the
crown
emma corin
princess diana into house yes
how on earth are you building up for
that pressure cooker
everyone has an opinion about her what's
that been like
everyone and all the noise being like
how are you gonna do this she's like
diana diana
um so yeah i had to kind of think okay
how am i actually going to get to grips
with this and
kind of put aside all of the hot air
about her basically and actually just
like
sit down and just like think about her
more as a person more as a character
and then i did a lot of character work
movement work a lot of like
psychology and figuring out what lay
behind
the things that she did or the things
that she does in the series
which was helpful as well yeah to kind
of get away from the like
the door she's like wake up every
morning
what was the thing that surprised you
shocked you the most
about her about her when doing that
psychology work
um
[Music]
that's such a good question i think one
of the things i did with polly bennett
who was um a fantastic
movement coach um that i worked with for
this and she did it we did a lot of the
psychological
journey of diana together and um
i remember early on we she was like what
animal do you think diane is
i thought oh diana like oh naive young
like come dear caught in the headlights
and polly was like sit with it for a few
days think about it and i was like
okay hopefully got that wrong um good
stuff
the school report is not gonna be great
yeah and so
and then i just got at the time i just
got a puppy and where i was living at
the time we had like a little um patio
outside
at the back of the house and these cats
would come and um
watch my puppy you know how cats have
this present
yeah and they just sit there and they
tilt their heads and they just watch him
and i was like oh my god it's diana
something about cats that's like
it's like bewitching the learning in a
little bit like come here to me
kind of thing and yeah very alluring
very mysterious and then me and polly
were started watching loads of cat
behavior videos
and there was literally videos where
cats are like doing the diana head tilt
and
it was phenomenal and i guess for me
that was a start
that was a start of kind of thinking
putting aside those like i guess like
impressions that i have of her as being
like
quite young quite like innocent and like
oh
everything's new and like quite naive
and like quite caught i guess a vehicle
in the headlights thing
to actually moving towards something
that's more complex there were so many
different sides of her that i
have discovered and yeah i guess that
was what surprised me
what do you think she's taught you about
yourself
oh she's made me
reflect upon the fine line that we all
tread all the time
between our happiness and
our sadness at once
and also the importance of recognizing
that how a person comes across only says
like five ten percent of what actually
is going on with them
the majority of pictures the majority of
footage the majority of
news if you look up anything to do with
diana will be
this incredibly powerful
like vivacious happy giving
person which she 100 was and i genuinely
believe she was that person but there
was
is it also 100 she was
so much more complicated and had so much
sadness and tragedy and
i think i spent a long time at the
beginning of this
process of kind of figuring her out
thinking we're kind of we've trained
ourselves
to think in binaries right which is just
problematic
i guess in that sense it must have been
paid quite a lot on your own
mental well-being in that sense yeah how
do you look after your own
mental well-being um yeah i did i was
like
also because the shoot was so long so it
was like a lot of long days doing a lot
of quite intense like
yeah this is difficult and also because
we dealt a lot with her mental health
and bulimia and
those scenes were very um tough
just started meditating that's new yeah
i did an amazing course and at the end
of the course they said
don't talk about this to anyone so i'm
doing a really good job
oh but it's actually really good and
it's i don't normally
um i'm normally quite skeptical about
stuff like that but actually it's
um made a huge difference from already
so we would recommend
yeah and that i think is good self-care
i think as well she's such a
iconic style icon we use that term
a lot but also beauty icon as well like
what is your own
journey with this concept of beauty
and your own beauty okay been like how's
that changed throughout your life
i was a huge tomboy when i was
younger i refused to dress in
feminine clothes at all um until i was
about
like 13 or 14 and then i went to a
um all girl school
and that was good there was no pressure
to look a certain way
for like guys or anyone
so i tend to actually not really
use a lot of makeup which i
really enjoy because i like the
naturalness
and i it's what i feel most comfortable
in doing um
but also i'm now like doing shoots and
stuff it's really interesting because i
feel like i'm learning a lot about
what it can do like it's quite fun and i
feel like i'm very late to the game i
feel like i should have had this
realization when i was like 13 not 24.
um
always felt like beauty for me and when
i feel most beautiful has always been
when i feel most myself and that has
always been for me
like the most stripped back i can be so
wearing the things i feel most
comfortable in
well i also kind of love in the shots
today because i've seen them
i just love it you just sat there and
you were like bit vampire you don't care
yeah that is so amazing to see thanks
yeah i really like it yeah i go through
phases of shaving and not shaving that's
that's yeah the beginning of this phase
of it
i'm now doing my legs as well which i
haven't not shaved my legs for
a while well i think that's so cool it's
so cool to just be like
thanks a 24 year old girl who's out
there in your career
living your life and just being like i'm
natural he cares getting it out
yeah yeah i think it's nice and also i
love how
it kind of still even though it's just
like something shouldn't be a big deal
it's still something that i feel like to
shoot today like we did today when it's
quite like
high fashion quite glamorous it's still
jars which is quite
interesting quite good do you know what
i mean we should just get to it like
everyone has body hair
at the end of the day where it's not
like oh she's wearing a chanel
like jumpsuit but she's got armpits
like candles
[Music]
yeah i kind of yeah i enjoy i enjoy that
but also one of the things what i find
so crazy about dana is
that she came into the public limelight
when she was like 19 right like
this really blows my mind stresses me
out because i think matt when i was 19 i
thought i knew everything
but we equally was aware that i i was so
young
yeah yeah i feel like i feel like i'm
from 19 especially like 19 to 24 i've
done
so much growing i feel like i'm an
entirely different person
in almost every single respect how do
you think you've changed
in that time what's been some like
turning points in like your
self-discovery would you say
i guess in terms of like yeah social
situations and like friends and
relationships who i want to be who i
want to surround myself with
and naturally a people pleaser yeah so i
tend to not
i have such a fear of like disappointing
people letting people down
i normally let kind of people or
situations walk all over me which
obviously in this industry can be quite
dangerous
because you kind of need to have a voice
yeah for instance like um oh are you
happy if we edit out your armpit hair oh
actually no i'm i'm not happy
if you do that i wouldn't like to keep
my arms yeah in this picture because i
think
it's important for me and i like it yeah
that kind of thing like a few years ago
i wouldn't i'd be like oh
yeah sure whatever yeah and it's kind of
discovering
my voice i guess and what i care about
because i think you discover what you
care about and you discover how
your relationship to that and how you
want to deal with it
i found this out that you when you
auditioned for drama school like two
times right
yeah and you didn't get it and then you
got in you're now
about to be in the biggest tv show
like of all time basically but
that's such an amazing success story to
say you've had these hurdles and you've
overcome them like
what did you learn about yourself in
those times when you were told no
and how empowering have you found a no i
feel like i'm in a
very fortunate position where i can look
back on it
in retrospect and be like oh look at
that i had to go through all that and
i'm here
and but i think even at that time when
it felt so
i honestly remember sitting on my bed
getting that letter from radha
and in all my naivety and
yeah just that golden hue of youth i
genuinely believed i would get in but i
remember i kept it i kept the letter i
might actually still have it
because i remembered that it was kind of
the first step
in thinking wow like if i really want to
do this
like how badly do i want this and if i
do all this and i'm just gonna have to
buckle up and deal with it
if i had started acting doing what i'm
doing now i
i mean like i would have been such a
different actor i would have been such a
different person
and i'm so glad that i had those years
i feel like i've been through i've
changed so much and
grown in a way that has only made what i
do
hopefully better what we what was it
like when you found out
you got this part um i mean honestly
insane i actually don't it's one of
those annoying things where i actually
literally
i wish i could remember everything like
the smell
what i was thinking what i was wearing
they took me to set
to well they said oh we needed to come
chemistry read with josh
um and they drove me to this like manor
house that they were filming in outside
of london
and and we me and josh around the scene
a couple of times
and then ben looked at suzanne and he
was like can i do it
and see sounds like yeah okay and then
he kind of like
got down and was like will you be our
diana i can't tell the one thing
i don't think he got i can't remember if
he got i want to say he got down on one
yeah but he was
i think he did like a lovely show
like a nice cutscene it was insane i
think honestly it felt a bit like the
world stood still for a second
um because it had been a long time um
a long process and i invested um
i really really wanted it
and you've got it honey and you got the
crown jewels to prove it
yes babes we're all about to enjoy it
yeah that's a crazy thought crazy
thought i just yeah
it's really gonna be really strange
because it's been like i guess
mine like the teams for so long it's
been our thing yeah
sending your child off to school yeah
yeah yeah bye diana have you got your
hey you got your cat lunch mom
your baby bells got your baby well babe
thank you so much sitting down in my
palace
oh my gosh thanks for having me freaking
out chat this is beautiful
and um good luck okay thank you keep
making it rain